تحت مشاهد الركام الذي كان يوما مدينه
واحياء ومنازل يعلق قرابه 1500 فلسطيني
بين الموت
والانقاض كانوا في منازلهم وبقوا فيها
جثامين قيد التشييع او احياء
ينتظرون لا يمكن للمسعفين او فرق الانتشال
الوصول اليهم فالبانيو
ولم يعد بمقدور فرق الانقاذ ان تزيح عنهم
ثقل الجدران والسقوف ان وصلت فالغ
الاسرائيليه تستهدف كل شيء حي في غزه حتى
المسعفين
وبحسب السلطات في القطاع قتلت قوات
الاحتلال عره مسعفين واصابت 27 بجروح
مختلفه ودمرت 23 سياره اسعاف منذ بدء
العدوان وحتى اعداد هذا التقرير دون ان
تخيفهم ليستمروا في العمل والدليل هو قصه
نجاه نادره في غزه ابطالها مسعفون وجيران
صغار وكبار صباح يوم دام استهدفت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه منزل ابو
القمصان وانهار على رؤوس العائله وصل
المسعفون ووسط بحر من الركام والانقاض
هناك احياء انتشل الاب اولا وفي سياره
الاسعاف اعطى عدد من دفن احياكم واحدكم
واحد بقى معك انت في الدار 29 واحد 29
واحد الله اكبر عاد المسعفون للبحث وبداوا
بانتشال عالقين
احياء
ليلتمس في المستشفى وليت الجميع ينجو كما
نجت ريم فبعده الى المبنى المستهدف تعمل
فرق الانقاذ هنا بمعدات بسيطه وبدائي
فالقطاع محاصر منذ 16 عاما وتمنع قوات
الاحتلال ادخال اي معدات لانقاذ الحياه
الى القطاع والقطاع يمتد على مساحه
360 ك مت مربعا تقريبا دمر جيش الاحتلال
اكثر من ثمانيه احياء ومناطق بشكل كامل
بمساحه تقترب من 24 كت مربعا في رقم
اولي وهذه المساحه هي التي يتوجب على فرق
الانقاذ والبحث العمل فيها مناطق سحقت
بالكامل تحتاج الى اليات ثقيله لرفع
الركام ومعدات تمكن الفرق الصحيه من البحث
عن
1500 ضحيه ومفقود حتى الان